- L'été est arrivé à Constanta.
Le soleil, la meesesesesesesese.
"Ça nous rappelle Odessa.
et elle est magnifique.
t t t t t rentrer à la maison."
Olga, Elena, Larissa, Tatiana,
Ina ne se connaissaient pas
quand elleinininininininininini.
Aujourd'hui, elles sont
insépa
i,i,i,i,i,i, elles sont
inséparables.
Elles habitent l'hôtel Mondial,,
nourries trois fois par jourete.
Les enfants s'y sont habitués,
mais devront bientôt
(en anglais)
q q q q q quelques semaines,
ces plages désertes de Constanta
seront bondées de vacanciers.
L'Hôtel leur a donnéleurs bagag.
Tatiana dit qu'un Roumai
à Mamaia, pas très loin,
mais elle ne sait
elle va pouvoir payer
la nourriture.
Les économies
avec la guerre qui s'installe.
La Roumanie leur a donné
une protecilililililililililili,
mais il faudra des mois,
sino a a a a a a apprendre
le roumain.
Les voir partir sans le sou,
leur dire de s'en aller,
crève le coeur de Stefan Onea,
un hôtelier.
C'est lui qui gère
Il a accueilli plus de
159 Ukrainiens, dont 60 enfants,
depuis la fin du mois
de février, sans recevoir
L'État lui a promis
éventuellement 10 euros
par personne par jour.
"Pas grand-chose", dit-il,
albrbrbrbrbrbrbrbrbres se louent
pour une centaine d'euros
aux touristes.
Et c'est le dilemme de
ces hôtels qui longent la côte
et qui se préparent
Car c'est la société civile,
pour les accueillir
avec dignité.
Cosmin est un coordinateur
qui fait le pont entre
plusieurs ONG à C
Il a aidé à ouvrir cette école
Ukrainiens avec Ludmila,
qui, elle aussi, est réfugiée
de la guerre.
Elle vient de recevoir
des ballons et des jouets
"Les enfants, dit-elle,
(chant)
Nous ne leur avons pas demandéoé
et ont entonné cette vieillechc.
Au fond de la classe,
esesesesesesesesesesesesesesese.
Il sort un petit morceauecececee
et le cache aussitôt que
la maîtresse s'approche de lui.
"C'est la tête de Poutine",
dit-il, mais c'est son secret.
Ces enfants ne peu
à cet homme qui détruit
leur maison et
leur mère.
rdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdements
qui s'intensifient à Odessa,
Anna se résigne à cette nouvelle
(chants d'oiseaux)
Elena ne sait pas quoi faire
et elle est dévastée.
Elle se lève, incapable de
parler. Elle nous explique
plus tard qu'elle aussi vient
d'apprendre qu'elle doit libérer
sa chambre la semaine prochaine,
et elle ne s'est
Adrian, qu
un hôtelier, déplore le fait
que l'Union européenne
n'ait toujours pas élaboré
de plan à long terme,
alors qu'il est évident
.............
Elle a débloqué un fonds de
3,5 milliards d'euros pour
les pays membres qui ont ouvert
leurs bras aux Ukrainiens.
Mais, c'est long.
pourpourpourpourpourpourpourpou,
il y a des centres
communautaires ou des dortoirs.
Et elles n'oseraient
jamais se plaindre.
(en ukrainien)ononononononononor
la reconnaissance envers
le peuple roumain et
sa générosité.
(chant)
Et elles chantent, elles aussi,
comme par instinct de survie,
leur mal du pays.
(chant)
Odessa, leur ville,
leur maison, leurs hommes,
so
mais ne leur aura jamais
parus si loi